seems like any other city in Kosovo but
it's one with deep ethnic divisions the
south is dominated by ethnic albanians
the north by ethnic serbs
the river Iber runs through the middle
the river isn't the only thing dividing
ethnic serbs and ethnic albanians
there's also politics a conflict and a
history dating back to the Ottoman
Empire there may be a bridge here but
it's not one connecting these two
communities it's a dividing line
in the South ethnic albanians are
grateful for the presence of NATO's
Kosovo Force
we are not afraid here because we have
the protection of K4 our cause of our
police and the cause of a security
forces it was different in the 90s and
until 99 when the war broke out but now
it's completely different as long as the
international support the least
subscribe gang there is no calmness
there are some citizens on the North
side who are once our enemies and still
are we are waiting for a solution
once you cross the bridge Serbian flags
are everywhere ethnic serbs have never
recognized kosovo's self-declared
Independence in 2008 they consider this
and all of Kosovo as part of Serbia
even the end of term for students is an
opportunity to declare their serve
nationalism
Kosovo is Serbia they changed no one on
the North side would speak to us on
camera we were told Time and Time Again
by people here that this is Serbia
the situation in the north is promoted
by official politics from Belgrade and
this is the problem serbs themselves the
victims both of the regime and Serbia
and also in recent months as we have
seen serious violations of collective
Serbian rights by our government in
Pristina
earlier in the week two ethnic albanians
were attacked here police stood just a
few hundred meters away kosovo's
interior Ministry described the
attackers as fascist militia both men
had to receive hospital treatment this
city epitomizes the challenge for the
Kosovo government tens of thousands of
ethnic serbs would rather be a part of
Serbia
than Kosovo
I said Kosovo